في عالم السياسه وعلمها حافه الهاويه
تهديد واستعداد بدخول حرب لا تبقي ولا تذر
انها اسلوب في اداره الازمات يلامس سقف
المجهول وتحقيق مكاسب معينه من خلال تصعيد
الازمات ودفع الاحداث الى حدود الصراع مع
ايهام الخصم بالاستعداد للتنازل او الرضوخ
حتى لو ادى الامر الى السقوط في هويه
الحرب والدمار
ويعرفه بفن القدره على الوصول الى حافه
الهاويه دون الدخول في الحرب من ابرز
الامثله على استخدام السياسه حافه الهاويه
بين الدول ازمه الصواريخ الكوبيه والنزاع
الذي اشتعل بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه من جهه والاتحاد السوفيتي حينها
وكوبر من جهه ثانيه
مراقبون يعتبرون تصرفات بوتان تدخل في
اطار هذه السياسه الرجل ما فتى يهدد
باستخدام كافه الاساليب في ساحه المعركه
ولمواجهه الخصوم باستعمال الاسلحه النوويه
فهو يبدو كرجل حرب في نظر البعض لكن
العارفين بعالم السياسه يقولون انه تهديد
فقط ليجنيه مكاسب على طاوله التفاوض
بلال الوجداني العربيه